سيل العقوبات المسلطه على ايران لا يزال
متواصلا ودفعه جديده من الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد ترى نور قريبا هذه المره فان طهران قد
تواجه عقوبات شديده بعدما صوت البرلمان
الاوروبي لصالح قرار يدعو الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى ادراج الحرس الثوري في قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه وقبل قليله افادت من
صدره ديكلوماسيه ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعمل
على تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه
دعوه البرلمان الاوروبيه هذه عقبتها ردود
فعل قلقه في طهران الرئيس الايراني رئيسي
قال ان سعيا الاتحاد الاوروبي لادراج
الحرس الثوري على لائحه الارهاب يتعارض مع
القوانين الدوليه وميثاق الامم المتحده
اما وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله الان فاجر بهذا الخصوص محادثات
هاتفيه مع الممثل الاعلى لسياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل انتقد فيه عبد
الحيان بشده ما اسمه النهج المتوتر
والانفعالي للبرلمان الاوروبي واعتبر
سلوكه غير مدروس وخطا
هيئته اركان الجيش الايراني بدورها تفاعلت
مع القرار من قبل البرلمان الاوروبي حيث
حذرت اوروبا من ادراج الحرس الثوري على
قائمه الارهاب معتبره ان في ذلك تهديدا
للامن القومي والدولي التي هذا او هذه
التطورات تاتي بينما اكد ذلك التماسيون ان
ممثلي الدول الاعضاء الاوروبي واثق
بالاجماع على فرد عقوبات على ايران